one of the things that makes cheese so
impressive is that there's so many
different types the better the milk the
better the cheese everybody believes
that you want cows that are happy it's a
very labor-intensive physical job that's
part of the fun i'm always amazed when i
just see hundreds of blocks of cheese
just sitting there
anytime i tell anyone that i work in
cheese almost everyone's immediate
reaction is i love cheese entire process
takes around five hours so we pasteurize
our milk fill our fat add culture after
that would be a rennet addition which
will coagulate the milk and you let it
sit undisturbed so it sets and makes
similar to like a pudding non-liquid
form
and at that point we cut and have curds
and white
it's great it feels good it's fun to
make something since the day i started
here it's always been a really cool
experience obviously the fact that i
love cheese and enjoy eating she has
made it really easy to get more in depth
about this i love being able to eat
cheese every day but i guess i could do
that no matter what job i had
it's very fast-paced and enjoyable to
keep kids in way moving keep them from
settling sticking back to each other
they want to stick together naturally it
is a lot of cheese for a couple of arms
it's a very labor-intensive physical job
that's part of the fun of it it's not
sitting behind a desk you know but it's
a tangible activity it's we're working
with our hands i think it continues to
be interesting and i love cheese
absolutely love it
and from there we are doing what's
called chattering and that's just a
process of stacking and flipping the
loaves of cheese to form proteins and
let the cheese acidify that's the big
step that's really what adds a lot of
the traits of our flagship
they're fairly heavy but you know it's
like anything else you build the muscles
with repetition and it's a good workout
there's always more to learn i work with
an incredible staff so it really is
awesome
there is currently some cheese at my
desk um it's all round all the time
i it's in my refrigerator at home at
least four different types of features
cheese
my sister sometimes gets overwhelmed
with how much cheese is in my fridge
it's a great situation i guess a fun way
to live
oh it's a whole world i mean there's
science there's certainly a learning
curve in the beginning people are like
wow these things are really heavy and
then a couple months into working here
you're just moving stuff around not even
thinking about it
[Music]
the flagship cheese is a delicious
cheese and that is because of a lot of
different things it's because of the
passionate involved people we have
making it by hand every day it's because
of the recipe that we've developed over
the years the details of our recipe have
an effect on what we're looking for what
we're trying to make
final step is hooping we put it into the
hoop it gets pressed into large blocks
the aging process is an integral part of
our cheese making process here the aging
process affects texture moisture flavor
profile
i always have a piece of black chip in
my fridge at home super creamy melts
really well it has enough flavor then
you know you're eating cheese always
loved a grilled cheese sandwich so it
seemed like a natural fit to come and
work at beaches
probably one of the things that makes
cheese so impressive is that there's so
many different types depends so much on
the person the situation everything
[Music]
one of the reasons i chose to buy a farm
is i've always loved the outdoors
so i wanted a place where i could make
cheese but i would want to relax outside
that's how it all began
the better the milk the better the
cheese everybody believes that you want
cows that are happy we use raw milk for
our cheese for for many reasons when you
eat a raw milk cheese you do pick up
more of the flavors of what the cows
were eating especially if they're
allowed to eat outside what makes it
unique compared to other cheeses is the
color it has natural and nettle
which is a natural coloring that gives
it that bright color makes it look in a
way almost like something from outer
space like the moon
[Music]
the more i got into
cheese making and visiting farms the
more i fell in love with it
you know one of the things i talk about
is the art of possibility that almost
anything is possible just about every
cheese made follows the basic steps so
how can this cheese be so different from
another cheese
i think what humans can bring to waking
cheese is that sense of the moment we do
follow a strict formula but your eyes
and your hands and your senses will tell
you that despite you know what you're
supposed to do maybe you stir it for an
extra couple minutes because of the way
it feels you want the right texture
there are wonderful things that can be
done with robux but there's certain
human emotions they can affect food or
anything else you do in a positive way
so if you really love what you're doing
you can't really program a robot to have
that same kind of love and passion for
it it'll do what you program it to do
but it'll end there
once you make the cheese there's a long
waiting period during the aging process
aged cheeses you go into it knowing that
you may not see the fruits of your labor
for six months to a year out so you have
to have a lot of patience with this
cheese
one of the things i really enjoy
is i have an excuse to build this below
ground cave
[Music]
when the cheeses are in the cave they're
still alive and the cultures are still
reacting the cheeses can just sit and
they develop this rind based on the
different strains of bacteria in the air
we do our best to give it the right
environment to thrive you have to try
and keep the air clean what it picks up
to create the molds adds another level
to the flavor and also the texture
because it's a high humidity environment
that's basically a drying process that
takes a long time staying there in a
year lets it develop its truest
potential
[Music]
when i'm in the cave i'm always amazed
when i just see hundreds of wheels and
blocks of cheese just sitting there
i'm sure there's several hundred
thousand dollars worth of cheese down
there
to me they seem happy
[Music]
when you complete a batch of cheese
whether it works out or not you feel
good because you've created it and done
it it's a wonderful feeling
the full circle value of doing
everything from start to finish is my
attempt at what one might call artistry
[Music]
you know when i taste cheese there is a
bit of magic i'm just blown away by it
that feeling doesn't change that's why i
take so much pleasure in improving it
maybe it's harder but that's what we're
trying to do
[Music]
my hopes and dreams for the future are
to
enjoy life the best way i can working on
a farm they're long hours there's no
doubt about it but if i wake up and i'm
healthy and i could make cheese gives me
reason for doing what i'm doing
the more i got into
cheese making the more i fell in love
with it
the fact that i love cheese and enjoy
eating she has made it really easy
you go into it knowing that you may not
see the fruits of your labor for a year
up but it's fun to make something it's
great it feels good
when i taste cheese there is a bit of
magic i'm just blown away by it super
creamy melts really well it really is
awesome the reason i do this because
almost anything is possible i foresee
continuing to make and eat great cheese
for all my days
[Music]
[Music]
you